all right this you have to see just
another complete
humiliation for the former president
donald trump who has been hyping up or
had been hyping up a press conference
for yesterday morning
during which he was going to make a
major announcement
right wing news network newsmax hyped it
up
fox news talked about it a little bit
but not nearly as much it leaked
the press conference would be trump
announcing that
he is suing filing a class action
lawsuit
against facebook against twitter against
google
because they banned him and the event
was
so humiliating and so absurd
that fox news even cut away from it
while trump was answering questions
let's look at some clips starting with
the big announcement from the former
president dude i'm filing
as the lead class representative a major
class action lawsuit against
the big tech giants including facebook
google and twitter
as well as their ceos mark zuckerberg
zucker sunder buche
that is really uh really something else
there and god bless
the united states yeah um just a little
more here
and jack dorsey okay so that's the big
announcement
trump is really really mad that he's not
allowed to
tweet and so he's suing everybody
and of course it's an embarrassment that
he's even doing this i mean
you know everything including even like
see how he has it sort of looks like the
presidential lectern
but it's not it's it's kind of like a
low-rent copy of it
um but where it really gets embarrassing
is the guy just doesn't understand the
first amendment
he just doesn't get it the founding
fathers
inscribed this right in the very first
amendment to our constitution because
they knew
that free speech is essential to the
prevention and look to the prevention of
hara hara that's h-a-h-r-r-a-h
if you're wondering and to the
preservation of our
republic this has nothing to do with the
first amendment
there is just nothing here related to
the first amendment and
later we're actually going to hear from
alan dershowitz who wants to try to say
this is a first amendment thing
this has nothing to do with the first
amendment these are private companies
with terms of service
and i don't want to get ahead of myself
we'll wait for the uh
we'll wait for the dershowitz thing
somehow at this event about trump suing
facebook and twitter
he ends up criticizing dr fauci a lot of
people ask me
about dr fauci i like dr fought you
actually get along with him great but
they said why didn't you fire him i said
no he was good
he'd recommend something i'd do the
opposite and we always turned out to be
around
so i don't even know how that came up
and then
at this point fox news just cut away if
you tuned to fox you
you no longer saw this you instead saw
a really important story where jason
chaffetz was talking about the origins
of kovid okay
trump was then asked about what happened
on january 6th and and the the question
was a good one the framing was
well you know the reason you ended up
banned from these platforms was because
of what you did on january 6th inciting
violence and all this different stuff
so what is your reaction to the fact
that that's what you did do you wish you
had done that differently
and somehow trump ends up talking about
antifa
just just to clarify who should be the
arbiter of
what's hate what's offensive what should
not be
published what goes beyond free speech
yeah and because so much of this
uh your banning has to do with uh
comments you made around january 6th
just to clarify further what did you do
to
stop the insurrection as some people
call it right and
why were you not able to stop it so that
whole uh
event unfortunate event just went
through congress and a report it was an
unfortunate event guys that's all
right it just that that's that's all it
was and stand by
yeah um unfortunate it was issued and my
name wasn't even mentioned
and i appreciate that i was surprised
frankly because i would have assumed
that they would
have come up with their typically biased
at least on the democrats
statement the report came out as you saw
two weeks ago my name wasn't even
mentioned that was an unfortunate event
uh i say though however people are being
treated unbelievably
unfairly so trump is saying the peop the
perpetrators are being treated unfairly
he's asked what did you do to stop it
which is a you know
indirectly reminding us that he fomented
it and he says
it was unfortunate but the people who
did the stuff are being treated really
unfairly they're the victims here
when you look at people in prison and
nothing happens to
antifa and they burned down cities and
killed people
and no guns in the capital that's not
true burned
except for the gun that shot ashley
babbitt
and nobody knows who that men were if
that were the opposite way
this is trump by the way continuing to
try to dox that officer
that man would be all over he would be
the
the guy's been cleared you know it's
funny because when they
um when there's a situation where the
left is saying hey this officer acted
inappropriately
they immediately say no these these
officers we have to defer to their
judgment they're in positions of danger
etc here there was an investigation and
it determined that the officer
did not not act inappropriately in
shooting ashley babbitt which was tragic
regardless but of course you shouldn't
have been there
um now all of a sudden trump wants the
guy doxxed if you can imagine most
well-known and i believe i can say man
because i believe i know exactly who it
is
but he would be the most well-known
person
in this country in the world but the
person that shot ashley babbitt
boom right through the head just boom
there was no reason for that
and why isn't that person being opened
up and why isn't that being
open them up just just just take a
scalpel to them and open them up so
trump somehow ends up talking about
you know antifa and who knows what else
and then this is sort of like trump's
new line
which really applies to himself and i
don't think that he really gets it
if you say it long enough hard enough
often enough
yeah people will start to believe it
true
that's what happened with russia that's
what happened with ukraine that's what
happened with
well the worst is when they don't say it
like
the laptop from hell that laptop from
hell still really bothering trump and it
is true
if trump repeats that he won the
election long enough and if the people
around him start to repeat it
people start to believe it and that's
exactly what we're what we're seeing now
let's just briefly go
back to the first amendment thing here
is alan dershowitz who has bizarrely
become
a big defender of trump over the last
few years saying this really is an
important first amendment case listen to
this
understanding is you have some of the
tobacco attorneys
involved in that class action suit
involved in this case
seems like a strong case but obviously
nothing is a slam dunk
this is the most important first
amendment case of the 21st century and
it's important because
it pits freedom of speech on the one
hand
against the first amendment on the other
hand that may sound paradoxical but
remember
it's the high-tech giants that are
banning freedom of speech they are
censoring but they're
claiming the right to do so under the
first amendment so this
is maybe the biggest distortion i could
imagine about this story
okay so dershowitz wants to claim this
is about
whose first amendment speech is is
uh uh trump's the other does
trump have a first amendment right to
post to twitter and facebook and google
which are private companies
or do facebook twitter and google
have a right not only under the first
amendment but also under
business regulation law which
republicans
are quick to defend when it's other
situations
to enforce terms of service so it is not
actually a first amendment case
that is the the big lie with this
lawsuit
is that this is really the first
amendment versus free speech and
censorship it's not
it is not that this is quite simply
republicans who say
don't regulate business now want the
government to force
twitter to allow trump to tweet
that is fundamentally what this is about
and it's outrageous and the entire event
was humiliating it's going nowhere it's
going absolutely nowhere
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the david pakman
show is supporting some of
our awesome sponsors today one of those
awesome sponsors is
sheath underwear a lot of us know all
too well
about the sticking and the rubbing and
the chafing with traditional
underwear especially this time of year
as the weather is getting warm
sheath underwear have created unique
boxer briefs with
multiple ergonomic compartments in the
front
preventing skin on skin contact
everything stays
separate comfortable dry and cool
no more sweatiness no more chafing no
more readjusting it's a lifesaver
sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
give
sheath underwear a shot i've had a great
experience i believe you will too
you can find the link underneath this
video and don't forget to use promo code
pacman for 20 off